This lecture is about the probabilistic
latent semantic analysis or P LSA.
In this lecture we're going to
introduce probabilistic latent semantic
analysis, often called the PLSA.
Say this is the most basic topic model.
Also, one of the most useful topic
models.
Now, this kind of models can in general
be used to mine multiple topics from
text documents, and PLSA is one of the
most basic topic models for doing this,
so let's first examine this problem in
a little more detail.
Here I show a sample article which is a
blog article about Hurricane Katrina.
An I showed some sample topics, for
example government response, flooding
of the city in new orlean's donation
and the background.
You can see in the article we use words
from all these distributions.
So we first for example.
See there's a criticism of government
response, and this is followed by the
discussion of flooding of the city and
donation, etc.
We also see background words or mixed
with them, so the goal of topic
analysis here is try to decode these
topics behind the text.
So segment of the topics to figure out
which words are from which distribution
and to figure out the first one of
these topics.
So how do we know there's a topic about
government response?
There is a public about the flooding of
the city.
So these are the tasks of topical
model.
If we can discover these topics can
color this words as you see here to
separate the different topics, then you
can do a lot of things such as
summarization or segmentation of the
topics, clustering of sentences, etc.
So the formal definition of the problem
of mining multiple topics from text is
shown here, and this is actually a
slide that you have seen in the earlier
lecture, so the input is the
collection, the number of topics and
vocabulary set.
And of course, the text data right?
And then the output is of two kinds.
One is the topic category
characterization Seedies HCI is a water
distribution and 2nd it's the topic
coverage for each document.
These are pie some ideas and they tell
us which document covers which topic to
what extent.
So we hope to generate these as output
because there are many useful
applications if we can do that.
So the idea of PLSA is actually very
similar to the two component mixture
model that we have already introduced.
The only difference is that we're going
to have more than two topics.
Otherwise it's essentially the same.
So here I illustrate how we can
generate the text that I was multiple
topics.
And naturally, in all cases of
probabilistic modeling, would want to
figure out the likelihood function.
So we will also ask the question what's
the probability of observing a world W
from such a mixture model?
Now if you look at this picture and
compare this with the picture that you
have seen earlier, you will see the
only difference is that we have added
more topics here.
So before we have just one topic
besides the background topical, but now
we have more topics.
Specifically we have K topics.
Now all these are topics that we assume
that exist in the text data, so the
consequences that our switch for
choosing a topic now is multiway switch
before it's just a two way switch.
Going to think of as flipping a coin.
But now we have multiple is.
First we can flip a coin to decide
whether we will talk about the
background.
So it's the background.
Lambda sub B versus non background.
So this one minus Lambda B gives us the
probability of actually choosing a
topic.
And background help.
After we have made this decision, we
have to make another decision to choose
one of these K distributions.
So there's a key way.
Switch here, and this is characterized
by the pies, and there's someone.
So this is just the different design
of switches, a little bit more
complicated, but once we decide which
distribution to use, the rest is the
same.
We're going to generate the world by
using one of these distributions,
assume here.
OK, so now let's look at this question
about the like hold.
So what's the probability of observing
a word from such a distribution?
What do you think?
Now we've seen this problem many Times
Now, and if you recall, it's generally
a sum over all the different
possibilities of generating the world.
So let's first look at the how the
world can be generated from the
background model.
The probability that the world is
generated from the background model is
Lambda multiplied by the probability of
the world from the background model,
right?
Two things must happen.
First, we have to have chosen the
background model.
And that's probability of Lambda sub B
and then the second we must have
actually obtained the world W from the
background, and that's probability of W
given sit out submit.
OK, so similarly we can figure out the
probability of observing the world from
another topic.
A topical theta sub k.
Now notice that here's a product of
three terms, and that's the cause.
The choice of topic theta sub
K only happens if two things happen.
One is we decided not to talk about
background, so that's probability 1
minus Lambda sub b.
Second, we also have to actually
choose.
Set us up.
K among these K topics.
So that's probability of serious up
cake or pie.
And similarly, the probability of
generating the water from the second
topic and his first topic popular like
what you're seeing here and then.
So in the end, the probability of
observing the world is just a sum of
all these cases.
And I have to stress again, this is a
very important formula to know because.
This is really key to know to
for understanding all the topic models and
indeed a lot of mixture models, so make
sure that you really understand the
probability.
Of W is indeed the some of these terms.
So next, once we have the likelihood
function, we would be interested in
knowing the parameters right?
So to estimate the parameters.
But first let's put all these together
to have the complete likelihood
function for PLSA.
Now the first line shows the
probability of a word as illustrated on
the previous slide and this is an
important formula as I said.
And so let's take a closer look at
this.
After that contains all the important
parameters.
So first we see Lambda sub b here.
This represents the percentage of
background words.
That would believe exist in the text
data and this can be unknown value that
we set empirically.
second, we see the background language
model and typically we also assume this
is known.
We can use a large collection of text
or use all the tests that we have
available to estimate the water
distribution.
Now next in the rest of this formula.
Excuse me, you see two interesting kinds
of parameters.
Those are the most important parameters
that we are asked, so one is pies and
these are the coverage of topic in the
document.
And the other is the word distributions
that characterize all the topics.
So the next line then is simply to plug
this in to calculate the probability of
document.
This is again of the familiar form
where you have some and you have
account of world in the document and
then log of a probability.
Now it's a little bit more complicated
than the two component because now we
have more components.
So the sum involves more terms and then
this line is just the like holder for the
whole collection and it's very similar.
Just accounting for more documents in
the collection.
So what are the unknown primers?
I already said there are two kinds on
his coverage.
One is awarded distributions.
Again, it's a useful exercise for you
to figure out exactly how many premise
there on here.
How many unknown parameters are there?
Now trying to figure out that question
would help you understand the model in
more detail, and it would also allow
you to understand what would be the
output that we generate when we use PLSA
to analyze text data, and these are
precisely the unknown parameters.
So after we have obtained the
likelihood function shown here, the
next is to worry about parameter
estimation.
And we can do the usual thing.
Maximum likelihood estimator.
So again, it's a constrained
optimization problem like what we have
seen before, only that we have a
collection of text and we have more
parameters to estimate and we still
have two constraints, different
constraint, two kinds of constraints.
One is awarded distributions.
All the words must have probabilities
that sum to 141 distribution.
The other is the topic coverage
distribution.
Anna Document will have to cover
precisely these K topics, so the
probability of covering each topical
would have to sum to one.
So at this point it's basically where
they find applied math problem.
You just need to figure out the
solutions to optimization problem.
There's a function with many variables
and we need to just figure out the
values of these variables to make the
function which its maximum.